А що якби ми забули про традиційне землеробство і стали вирощувати їжу там,
де живемо, та зменшили б тим самим свій вуглецевий слід?
Загугліть: Аквапоніка. Це метод, який деякі науковці
розглядають як спосіб розвантажити нашу екосистему.
Монокультури, а також надмірне використання штучних добрив і пестицидів
призвели до величезної деградації екосистем та біорізноманіття.
Сільське господарство становить приблизно п’яту частину
всіх парникових газів, що викидаються у світі.
При цьому приблизно половина населення Землі відчуває
серйозний дефіцит води протягом щонайменше одного місяця на рік.
Ця ферма в Ейндговені у Нідерландах претендує
на вирішення усіх цих проблем.
-Це приголомшливо!
-Ви цього не очікували? Молочний завод…
-Це схоже на космічний корабель.
-Що це?
-Це аквапонічна ферма.
Тім Елфрінг - співзасновник стартапу Phood Farm.
У цій невеликій теплиці посеред міста він вирощує три види салату -
загалом до 200 кг на тиждень.
Але при цьому він використовує на 90 відсотків менше води
порівняно із звичайними фермерами.
У спекотний день у сільській місцевості є водяна гармата,
яка стріляє водою - бум, бум, бум, бум, бум.
І дуже багато води, питної води, втрачається.
А в цій системі, оскільки вона закрита, вода переробляється.
Єдина втрачена вода - це випаровування
або те, що використовують рослини.
Спочатку насіння проростає, як у звичайному ґрунті.
Потім воно росте на пінопластових пластинах -
лише коріння у воді, без ґрунту. Через шість тижнів вже можна вживати.
-На смак неймовірно, так?
-Так, дивовижно, ще й надзвичайно свіже.
Аквапоніка - це поєднання гідропоніки, тобто вирощування
рослин без ґрунту, та аквакультури - вирощування риби.
Разом ці дві системи утворюють майже ідеальний екологічний цикл.
Тут ми маємо овочі, які, так би мовити, живляться коропами.
Вода, багата рибним послідом, перекачується
через ці труби в резервуар. А бактерії, що природним чином
зустрічаються у ґрунті та воді, перетворюють потенційно
токсичний аміак із риб'ячого посліду на природне добриво,
яке необхідне для росту рослин. Вони поглинають поживні речовини,
фільтрують воду і повертають вже чисту воду до водойми.
Таким чином можна вирощувати помідори, салат, баклажани
та багато інших овочів та рослин.
Багаторічні культури, такі як яблука, апельсини, чай, кава або какао,
не вирощуються в цій системі.
Залежно від виду риби та овочів, деяким з них потрібно
мало добрив або взагалі нічого.
Нам не потрібні пестициди. Так, сюди не потрапляють природні хижаки,
тому що тут усе контролюється.
Штучні пестициди можуть завдати шкоди рибам
і порушити екологічний баланс.
Що стосується вартості, то має бути штучне освітлення -
особливо у північних країнах. І це вагомий чинник
разом з енерговитратами, необхідними для вентиляції
та перекачування води. Ось чому використання
енергоефективних теплиць та відновлюваних джерел енергії
дуже важливе.
Наскільки б технічно складною не була ця система,
одне з перших штучно створених середовищ,
що використовувало подібну екосистему для сільського господарства,
насправді було ще в ацтеків у Мексиці.
У мілководних річках вони будували чінампас -
плаваючі поля з кількома сільськогосподарськими культурами,
землею та компостом.
У Китаї та Південно-Східній Азії також вирощування рису
та риби на одній землі має традиції, яким уже багато століть.
Метод використовується у деяких місцевостях і сьогодні.
-Отже, вам зовсім не потрібні антибіотики?
-Ні. -Чому? -Нам тут це не потрібно, бо вода добре очищається.
Закритий водний контур і великий простір полегшують
створення здорового середовища для риб.
На відміну від інших аквапонічних систем, ці коропи
під назвою кой не розводяться для того, щоб їх їли.
Їх продадуть далі тим, хто розводить коропів кой.
Після початкового пілотного етапу Тім Елфрінг та його партнери
можуть у майбутньому перейти до масштабного виробництва
та розведення їстівної риби.
Салат збирають у той самий день, коли він потрібен,
і доставляють його безпосередньо до магазинів та ресторанів
органічної їжі по цілому місту. Ціни конкурентні.
Стартап Phood Farm поки не приносить великих прибутків.
Але попит зростає, і вони вже мають плани збільшити виробництво.
Із щорічним обсягом 600 мільйонів доларів світовий ринок
аквапонічної продукції все ще відносно невеликий.
Рентабельність значною мірою залежить від розташування
та проєктування систем, а також від місцевої харчової промисловості.
Серед основних перешкод для початку масового виробництва -
високі початкові інвестиційні вимоги та потреба
у спеціалізованих знаннях.
Я думаю, що для продовольчої безпеки нам потрібні
великі приміщення. Я собі це бачу так, що протягом
найближчих 5-10 років, не буде систем, які лише вироблятимуть
ту чи іншу частину - лише рибу чи лише рослини.
Тож у нас будуть якісь комбіновані системи.
Якщо ви зацікавлені у сільському господарстві,
у соціальних мережах багато порад щодо того,
як побудувати власну аквапонічну систему...
у вашій квартирі, на балконі чи в саду.